Ok, show of hands, who would fly upside-down
in a jet?
But how does it…
Some planes can do crazy things, but one of
the most extreme is the ability to fly at
high-speeds upside-down.
And not all planes can do this.
Planes fly when air moving around the wing
lifts the plane into the sky.
With upside-down-flying it get’s a little
more complicated.
There are two main factors to consider when
thinking about wings: the wing’s design
and “the angle of attack.”
Normally, a wing has to be shaped very specifically
to nudge the air over the top, allowing the
air below to create lift.
When a plane has to be able to fly both ways
the wing has to be shaped differently.
On commercial planes, the wings are rounded
in the front, bulged on top and flat on the
bottom.
The helps the air move faster over the top,
which in turn, makes the air less dense, helping
the plane fly.
Now that’s all fine if you’re trying to
fly long distances at a steady speed, but
flying upside-down requires a whole different
thought process.
Planes built to fly upside-down have uniquely
shaped wings.
Fighter jets, for example, have crazy thin
wings, which allow them to go faster while
producing more lift.
Stunt planes have symmetrical wings.
Meaning they’re curved on both the top and
bottom to allow air to easily glide over the
wings even when flying upside-down!
These planes are also a heck of a lot smaller
and lighter than the massive planes we fly
across the country.
The ‘angle of attack’ also affects these
upside-down movements.
The angle of attack represents the measurement
of how high the front of the wing is tilted.
More tilt means more lift.
When the pilot flies upside down they have
to understand their angle of attack.
Or the angle of the airplane’s wing through
the air.
To little angle of attack, and there’s not
enough air below the wing to lift it up.
So, if they push the nose into the sky -- even
while upside down, they can generate lift
on a thin, symmetrical wing.
Voila!
Upside-down flight (for a bit).
Think about “flying” your hand out a car
window…
If you keep it level it glides through the
air.
Tilt the leading edge up and the air pushes
on the bottom of your hand generating lift!
Fighter jets and stunt planes are a lot lighter
and smaller than regular commercial planes,
which is what gives them the ability to tilt
their noses skyward and get much higher angles
of attack.
This allows the planes to fly up, over and,
breathtakingly upside-down!
It’s safe to say that you’ll probably
never have to worry about a pilot taking you
on a topsy-turvy joyride… that is unless
you’re riding shotgun in a fighter jet.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
I actually rode in a fighter jet once.
The whole experience was incredible.
I definitely threw up everywhere.
Learn all about it here.
Would you fly upside-down?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to subscribe
and come back here for more Seeker.